So, L3 Microkernel shares to debunk the myth about Microkernel-based
operating system structure. It goes beyond that, and it has a thesis for
how operating systems should be structured. The first
principle advocated by L3 is that the Microkernel should
have minimal abstractions that includes support for address
spaces, threads, interprocess communication,
and generating unique IDs. Why do we need these abstractions in
the microkernel? The argument is that these four abstractions
that I mentioned, address space, threads, IPC, and
UID, Our extractions that are needed by any subsystem that
provides a functionality for end users in an operating system and therefore,
the principle of optimizing the common
case suggests that these abstractions should be
part of any microkernel. The second
thesis coming out of L3 microkernel experience
is that microkernels are process specific
in implementation. In other words, if you
want an efficient implementation of microkernel, you have to take advantage of
whatever the hardware is offering you. Which suggests that micro kernels by the
very nature are non-portable if you want to focus on performance. Making a
micro kernel processor independent is essentially
sacrificing performance. So if you put these
two principles together, what L3 is advocating is the right set of
kernel abstractions and processor-specific implementation. If you do
that, then you can build efficient processor-independent
abstractions at the upper layers. All of the services
that we associate in a monolithic kernel like
a UNIX operating system such as,
file system, network protocols, scheduling, memory
management. They all can be implemented in a processor independent way on top
of a microkernel that provides the right set of abstractions and exploits
whatever the hardware gives in terms
of capabilities to get an efficient processor
specific implementation. That's the thesis of
L3 microkernel, processor specific kernel and
process the independent abstractions at higher
layers of the operating system stack.